hey everyone bandit here you ever had a
friend or even just acquaintance that
for some reason you can't explain just
kind of hates you well our best boy link
has a real knack for attracting those
kinds of people let me tell you from his
most recent adventure breath of the wild
which includes a flying talking piece of
kfc that hates his guts all the way back
to the legendary ocarina of time which
included a little guy that similarly
hated link's guts not sure what it is
about link that makes people react this
way to him sometimes maybe it's the
whole goody two-shoes thing he's got
going on or maybe it's those blue blue
eyes but either way as annoying as these
kinds of characters are would it make it
any better if you knew that they felt
badly about it afterwards well what if i
told you that we can actually deduce
that this is indeed the case for mido
that cokery jerk from our childhoods but
for those who maybe haven't played the
game before let me recap real quick just
who mido is and what role he played in
ocarina in the kokiri forest which is
where the game starts and where our
young hero link grew up all the way
until the ripe age of 9 or 10 when he
was tasked with saving the world you
know normal childhood stuff anyway maida
was a notable member of the kokori the
boss of the kokori in fact and he served
as a literal physical roadblock with
some epic sidestepping skills and forced
link to go and find the cokery sword i
know it's so tiny and a deku shield
after you fetch these two items he will
begrudgingly step aside and allow you to
pass through and encounter the deku tree
obviously mido is a necessary piece of
game design from nintendo to force
players to at least learn a couple
things and get their first sword and
shield before taking on their first
dungeon but as far as lore or even
personal reasons go he probably stopped
link from progressing because he's madly
jealous of link since in his own words
he can't believe that the benevolent
deku tree would ask to talk to link
personally and not mido and of course
there's also a girl involved saria you
know the sage of the forest who mido
clearly had feelings for yet was never
able to get serious to notice him like
she did link and there's also the fact
that the deku tree dies after link goes
to see him so yeah i can understand why
he'd be a bit salty of course it still
doesn't make it right anyway that was
mido most ocarina of time players
remember him as some jerk and move on
but later on in the game after link
obtains all three spiritual stones as a
kid and opens the door of time in the
temple of time and claims the master
sword for his own and subsequently
allows ganondorf free access to the
triforce
as most know link is then able to travel
into the future by seven years and
explore the shattered world of hyrule as
an adult if you go back to the kokori
forest which you do have to do in order
to complete the forest temple you'll
notice that monsters abound where they
previously did not talk to a cokery
child inside of serious house and
they'll tell you that mido said that the
great deku tree withered because a boy
named link did something wrong to it and
only seria defended link before she left
to the forest temple talk to another
kokri in mido's house and they'll tell
you that the monsters are here because
of the deku tree's death now this is
some pretty pertinent information
because it's made clear to us that not
only was the deku tree's death pinned on
link by mido but that also means that
since monsters are now ruining the once
peaceful kokori forest due to maido
spreading this misinformation about link
killing the deku tree the kokori now
associate link with the appearance of
the monsters and therefore now hate link
all of them do except for seria
according to that cokery in series house
fast forward a bit and link has to
traverse the lost woods in order to find
the forest temple and blocking the right
path once again is everyone's favorite
fiery redheaded shorty mido he doesn't
recognize you as link even though he
notices that you're wearing quote
co-curish clothing and refuses once
again to allow you passage until you
play serious song of course he notes
that seria only ever taught that song to
her close friends and though he's
confused as to who you are in light of
this he finally lets you pass so that
you can go and meet seria and complete
the forest temple after completing the
temple if you go back and talk to mido
link explains that seria isn't coming
back because she's now a sage to which
maida responds by saying his last and
most important lines in the entire game
oh i see serio won't ever come back but
i i made a promise to seria if link came
back i would be sure to tell him that
sarah had been waiting for him because
seria really
liked
hey you if you see him somewhere please
let him know and also i'm sorry for
being mean to him tell him that too and
after this you never speak to him again
though he is seen once more at the very
end of the game about halfway through
the credits roll the music and visuals
change pretty drastically into a full-on
outdoor dance party at lawn lawn ranch
involving pretty much everyone you meet
in the entire game and i do mean
everyone there's the gerudo the zora the
dancing couple even big goron and the
cokery children the dance party takes
place after link and zelda defeat
ganondorf at the end of the adult
timeline as evidenced by malin's age
since she's grown up by the time of this
dance party and it's assumed that
everyone is so happy and dancing and
having a good time because zelda after
the ending fight was able to retake her
kingdom as its rightful ruler and
explain to everyone the tale of link the
hero who traveled through time to defeat
the aforementioned ganondorf which is
why the tale of the hero of time has
become legend by the time the wind waker
takes place and since ganondorf is no
more that means they can all go back to
living their happy normal lives after
seven long years of serving an evil king
it's a happy time which is why there's
something so off about one of the
characters who appears here see the
cokery are dancing and playing around
and having a good time but one of them
is not you don't see mida with the other
children in fact you don't see him at
all until after the music dies down and
he's shown to be sitting away from
everyone else alone well not alone he's
got the zora king with him but i'm sure
the zora king is just sitting out there
because he can't very well do much else
now can he and moving anywhere would
probably take him about
the essence of the sages causes mido to
briefly look skyward but then the camera
zooms off and that's it for the scene
and mido it always struck me as
strangely important that mida would be
secluding himself from everyone else
looking sadly at the ground why would he
be over here sulking it up when there's
a party to be had involving everyone
including all his close friends in the
cokery being sad because of losing seria
is one thing but most of the people
dancing around the fire have also lost a
notable member of their people groups
due to the calling of the sages yet
there's still plenty of cause for
celebration i.e the defeat of ganondorf
i think mido's sulking behavior here was
meant to tell us a story about how he's
responding to the news about link saving
the world and let me explain that
further by way of a question what is the
only difference between mido and
everyone else at the party the
difference is maida was the only person
in the entire world of hyrule who didn't
believe in link not only that he's the
only person who actually tried to stop
link and put him down being jealous of
him the entire time and we know that
these kinds of self-aware sorrowful
emotions were somewhere inside him
because of his words to adult link where
he says that he's sorry for how he
treated link as a child he said that to
a complete stranger adult meaning he's
dealing with immense feelings of guilt
now i could end the episode right here
and say that prideful kid gets sad out
of guilt and that's the end of the story
and if you only looked at ocarina of
time that's really all you could get
from this information but there's one
more mention of mido later on in the
zelda series that got my theory senses
tingling see if you fast forward all the
way to the end of the fallen timeline
which is the alternate adult timeline
that takes place if link is killed by
ganondorf instead of killing ganondorf
enabling ganondorf to take the triforce
4 himself you eventually come to the
last game in the timeline zelda 2 the
adventure of link in the game there are
seven notable towns eight if you include
the ruins of old kasuto some of the
towns are named after the sages from
ocarina of time the towns of syria
darunia ruto rauru and naburu now in
real life of course since zelda 2 came
out a good decade before ocarina of time
clearly the town names were the
inspirations for the names of the sages
as far as development is concerned but
in regards to in-universe lore since
ocarina of time takes place before zelda
2 the towns were in turn actually named
after the sages which makes sense since
the hero of time would have fallen in
this timeline according to the backstory
of a link to the past the sages and
people of hyrule were the ones who
stepped up to seal ganondorf within the
sacred realm no doubt exalting their
statuses as heroes which is definitely
worth naming a town after but there are
a few town names i didn't mention the
final three are named kasito old kasuto
and the harbour town of maido that's
right maido has a town named after him
in the fallen timeline now names in
zelda games are always extremely
important i mean half of zelda theories
out there are based off of similar names
and for good reason kakariko is always
called kakariko beetle is always called
beel and imba is always called impa
right the zelda dev team have always
used names to connect pieces of lore or
locations over the metanarrative that is
the universe of zelda so that begs the
question if the towns of zelda 2 are
mostly named after the sages who are the
heroes of the people what could mido
have possibly done to exalt his status
in a similar manner you could say it's
because he was the leader of the kokori
but seria is already a sage of the
cokery which pretty much overshadows
anything mido could have been by just
being their boss i think it's something
different so let's rewind once again to
the party scene at the end of ocarina of
time notice that the kokori are outside
of the kokori forest which is something
that the kokari said earlier in the game
would kill them if they left according
to the deku tree clearly though they're
not dead so what does this actually mean
the deku tree wouldn't lie right in my
opinion since link and the kokori
children of the lost woods were based on
and heavily inspired by peter pan and
the eternally child like lost boys which
miyamoto confirmed in an interview with
the french magazine game cult it
probably means that leaving the lost
woods would result in the cokery giving
up their immortal forms as children and
aging as a normal human being would of
course leaving neverland leading to
aging is debatable in peter pan lore but
the movie hook which featured an aged
peter pan for the first time played by
the actor and zelda fanatic robin
williams may he rest in peace did come
out in 1991 a full seven years before
ocarina of time so the very famous movie
could have inspired the idea we do also
have some slight in-universe evidence of
this being true though what i'm about to
say could easily be an entire theory
video on its own but let's jump over to
the child timeline which takes place
before ganondorf is able to conquer
hyrule but yet does not feature the deku
tree the cokery or their evolved forms
the koroks or does it see it's been a
theory for a while now that the people
of oron village may actually be the
kokori that turned mortal and aged a bit
due to several reasons which i'll state
briefly one they border the fair on
woods which has the forest temple inside
it which is a get this giant
hollowed-out tree with a parasite living
inside that you have to cleanse with the
cocaine symbol literally all over the
inside sound familiar add this to the
fact that a blond-haired ordonian man is
named fedo and in the alternate adult
timeline there is a blonde-haired
cockery named fedo could twilight
princesses fado and ordonian villagers
be the cokery who left the forest or
protection of the deku tree and
therefore began to age as mortals like i
said it's a theory in and of itself but
for the purposes of this video let's
just assume for a moment that it is true
now back to the theory in the downfall
timeline this party would not have taken
place instead people would learn that
ganondorf had killed link the hero which
is kind of a bummer this means that it
was up to the sages and the people of
hyrule to fight against ganon's forces
that would soon be pouring out of the
dark world this event is called the
imprisoning war in zelda lore and it is
the only thing that we know of that
happens between ocarina of time and a
link to the past and notably the rest of
the timeline following a link to the
past features no cokery or deku tree so
something tells me that whatever mido
did to make a name for himself to the
hylians who would have been the ones to
name the towns of zelda 2 it would have
had to happen after ocarina of time and
before a link to the past in the
imprisoning war so here's my speculation
based on everything we've talked about
could it be that mido the one who
assumedly already knows how to use a
sword and a shield and who was jealous
of link being called upon to be a hero
by the deku tree heard about link
falling heroically in combat against
ganondorf who was also responsible for
killing the deku tree by the way and due
to his guilt and newfound sense of
vengeance decided to leave the kokori
forest to join the fight against ganon
potentially even taking the cokery with
him and what if this war lasted a while
like wars can years even which would
have been long enough for mido and
potentially the other kokori children to
grow up and what if this led to mido
becoming a war hero the leader of the
kokori army it is an intense contrast to
the kid bully that we grew up knowing
but given all the facts across the zelda
universe and the disappearance of the
kokiri following the events of ocarina
of time i think this is the best answer
to why maida would have his name exalted
to the status of the sages but of course
this is all just my theory there are
still things we don't know such as who
kasito is and why a town would be named
after them in that case and there is of
course the possibility that the name
mido was just that a name but what do
you guys think let me know in the
comments below also thank you so much
for watching please consider leaving a
like if you enjoyed the theory it helps
much more than you might know and
subscribe to stick around for all the
other juicy videos that i make about
your favorite games huge thanks as
always to my bandit crew who make these
videos possible including the fabulous
fellow youtuber hannah yosora who
recently joined the ranks of my elite if
you're interested in joining up please
feel free to check out the join button
below or in the description that's all
i've got for this one so as always i
hope you have a wonderful rest of your
day this is masterton abandoned looking
forward to seeing you next time and
signing out peace
[Music]
you